At its core, American Dad is a family sitcom…
crossed with the craziest elements of spy
movies and science fiction.
More than 200 episodes of the series have
aired, centered around CIA agent Stan Smith,
his family, their live-in alien Roger, and
a talking fish named Klaus.
Here's a look behind the scenes of American
Dad!
The evolution of Klaus
American Dad! is almost definitely the only
show on TV to have a goldfish who speaks with
a German accent.
That's Klaus, a once-human German ski jumper
whose brain was switched a goldfish by cutting-edge
CIA technology — and who now lives in a
bowl at the Smith residence.
"Hour 36.
The sun seems like it comes every day now.
The cat's back!"
Not only was Klaus once human, he was also
once French.
Series co-creator Seth MacFarlane explained:
"Dee Baker… the character of Klaus was originally
supposed to be French."
"I remembered that Dee had come in to do some
animal sounds on Family Guy and had kinda
warmed himself up in the booth by doing this
German accent."
MacFarlane fell in love with Baker's alternate
take on the fish, and Baker got the part,
beating out Billy West and John DiMaggio of
Futurama.
They dropped the politics
A show about a very conservative CIA agent
who lives and works in the Washington, D.C.
area is bound to be at least a little political,
but the American Dad! writers have toned down
that kind of content over the years.
It's not because the show's networks, Fox
or TBS, told them to, or that they were afraid
of offending viewers.
They found that political references dated
the show.
For example, in 2005, President George W.
Bush nominated White House counsel Harriet
Miers for the Supreme Court.
American Dad!
Wrote in a joke about her, but Bush withdrew
the nomination.
A few months later, the episode with the Miers
joke aired.
Co-creator Mike Barker told The AV Club,
"I remember watching on air and having to
Google who our own joke was, because it had
been so long since the joke was pitched."
In the end, American Dad moved away from politics
to remain more relevant in reruns.
Going too far
American Dad! can push the envelope in terms
of content, but there have been only a few
times cast or crew drew a line.
Patrick Stewart, who plays CIA director Avery
Bullock, didn't want to deliver a joke that
strongly suggested his character was a creep,
according to a 2012 San Diego Comic Con panel.
Even though Stewart had no qualms earlier
about singing a suggestive Oingo Boingo song.
"I, I love girls, they make me feel so good.
I, I love girls, they make me feel so bad."
Another instance of self-editing personally
involved co-creator Seth MacFarlane.
There was a reference in a script to a character
having lost a lot of weight, or, as the original
script called it, "doing a reverse Jason Segel."
MacFarlane, who's friends with Segel, asked
for a rewrite.
Writers gave Steve's voice actor, Scott Grimes,
the option to say "Russell Crowe," which then
made Grimes uncomfortable.
They ultimately decided on "Vince Vaughn,"
but still recorded him saying Russell Crowe,
"in case it was funnier."
Pulled from the schedule
It's not just a few lines that have had to
be cut from the script — at least twice,
episodes were significantly delayed so they
wouldn't seem to make light of national tragedies.
In April 2011, Fox planned a night of crossover
episodes where a hurricane would impact the
lives of characters on all three of Seth MacFarlane's
animated shows, American Dad!, Family Guy,
and The Cleveland Show.
In the weeks leading up to that event, storms
and tornadoes ravaged the southeastern United
States, and Fox pulled the hurricane-themed
episodes, pushing "Night of the Hurricane"
to October 2011.
The following year, the American Dad! episode
"Minstrel Krampus" was scheduled to air on
December 16th.
The Christmas-themed episode included an extremely
violent scene in which Santa and Stan Smith
storm the castle where the mythical creature
Krampus lives, violently killing Beauty and
the Beast-styled animated objects.
Just before it aired, Fox removed "Minstrel
Krampus" from its schedule in light of that
week's tragic school shooting at Sandy Hook
Elementary School in Connecticut.
The episode ultimately aired a year later.
The musical cast
American Dad! employs some top-notch vocal
talent, and some of its cast members have
such skilled and varied vocal abilities that
they've released albums.
In 2012, Rachael MacFarlane, who voices Hayley
Smith, released an album called Hayley Sings,
a collection of sultry nightclub jazz; the
American Dad! episode "Love, A.D.
Style."
in which Hayley becomes a nightclub singer,
features a couple of songs from the album.
Scott Grimes, whose vocal talents are also
often used in the show, has released three
albums: a self-titled pop record in 1990,
Livin' on the Run in 2005, and Drive in 2010.
And singing traditional pop standards with
a big band is just one of Seth MacFarlane's
many jobs.
He's made three albums of the stuff: Music
is Better Than Words, Holiday for Swing, and
No One Ever Tells You — which actually hit
number one on Billboard's jazz albums chart.
Have a great night
"Bye, have a beautiful time!"
Underdog Productions' end card for every episode
of American Dad! uses a video of a smiling
man giving a wave and a thumbs-up, usually
wishing everyone a good night.
"Bye, have a great time!"
According to the show's DVD commentaries,
he's a guy identified only as Security Officer
Peña who worked at the building where Underdog
Productions makes the show.
Peña no longer works there, but his presence
remains a fixture at the end of each episode…
even when he's not there.
"Come back, you cowards, I'll kill you!
I'll hunt you down and kill you!
Bye!
Have a beautiful time!"
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!